[Music]
please welcome to the show the one the
only Queen
[Applause]
this is amazing thank you
thank you so much for having me
welcome cool you got some nice loungy
chairs in here get comfy you're home all
right uh Queen Latifah you are here
because you are an Emmy and Grammy
winner an oscar-nominated actor and
you've been in more movies and TV shows
than should be allowed and in doing so
you've inspired a billion people just
like me to think that maybe what we have
to offer is valid you have mastered
everything you've ever tried you are the
literal best at a [ __ ] ton of things
you're America's sweetheart I love you
thank you for being here thank you so
much
all right
Okay so
Queen Latifah this is what happened just
the other day what happened I'm home
with my with my dad and I sit down
because it's Sunday night and I know
what I'm doing and then dad comes and he
sits now next to me we're all in the
living room and then we're searching for
the remote mom comes in and she sits
down I said what are y'all doing they
said we're watching The Equalizer I said
that's what I'm doing little dude I know
we all
equalizer
hey
we adore that show
um does your family also love The
Equalizer oh no my family loves The
Equalizer yes yes yes like there were
some days I wasn't sure I was walking
back in that building my my grandmother
would be like oh hell
my baby I love you I love that show I
love the action on that show and I'm
like oh little do you know okay go to
work go to work because man needs The
Equalizer and now yes she is my
inspiration she's the wind beneath my
wings so
when uh when I'm all stressed out I just
go in there and they get out on some bad
guy
Kick-Ass is so good it just feels so
good thank you we don't get a lot of ass
kickers around here we kick a lot of ass
but we don't get a lot of air
um oh my mom wants me to ask you when
are you going to fall in love with Dante
well who said they aren't in love
laughs
I don't know I can't live like this I
just when when you guys finally I love
that you just freaking die I'll die I
can't wait who says we haven't guessed
now let me stop it
guys rumors are getting started and
they're getting started right here um
but wait something very cute happened to
you oh
um you attended a ceremony last month in
New Jersey where they opened a steam
Academy named after your mommy who
worked in that District as a teacher
yeah now do I have a picture of him
ah I do there's Nana and that's my
grandma
that's my grandma right there
I'm looking Shawn
superintendent that's a nice picture was
she a supporter of your music
hip-hop yes yes
she has supported everything I've done
except for
she tries and then sometimes I'm like
Nana you can't see this one
that's not gonna work she's a good old
Christian lady she is like no she tried
to watch Star a couple of times this TV
show I had and uh she can't watch that
because everybody else is watching it so
she was like I gave it 15 minutes
but I'm not gonna be able to do that one
baby
and then she tried again she was like I
gave it 15 more minutes but I was like
Nana just stop so she she no she
couldn't it's too hot too much too too
much going on on that show yeah not
every not everything's for Nana not
everything is fine she's invited to
everything she's invited everything
but I make shorts but that's why I make
sure I make something that Nana can
watch you really do I really go out of
my way to make sure I give her something
to watch well I will never not watch
whatever you are doing
partnership with Lenovo and why you
think it's vital that we all
um support small businesses well small
businesses are the backbone of our
communities you know they're they
they keep us going they keep us going
um the novo came to me with this
initiative and I thought why not of
course this is amazing they are going to
select a special winner who will be able
to get cash
uh technology
and mentorship from me one-on-one
and with their cool yes
and um all they have to do is make a
video like 30 seconds to like maybe two
minutes two minutes long somewhere in
there Shark Tank style you know and
Pitch their business that's not
that's excellent uh I also have to ask
you about my favorite thing in the world
Living Single it turns 30
um in a little bit Living Single heard
of it best TV show in the history of
Television but I love it so bad now I
hear you're on a text chain with
everybody from Living Single are you on
a tech stream with the cast of Living
Single if so pull out your phone and
read it
laughs
I hid my phone because I knew you were
gonna ask that
um I'm definitely on a text chain yes so
your Max's and your regimes your cows
your oovies everybody and yvettes on it
it's like every Kim Fields everybody's
on everybody's on the texting oh my God
and we just like hit each other up every
once in a while and it just turns it it
is really a show it's funny they are so
funny that the text chain itself turns
into Ridiculousness and we just have fun
just laughing with each other over text
would you ever do a remake of Living
Single
sure why not
why not I if you hadn't said anything
else I would have laid down and cried no
I can't look at that here are some rapid
fire questions are you emotionally
prepared I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready
you're multi-hyphen it you have to
choose one rapper actor host singer
comedian rapper oh
have you ever been bad at anything if so
what is it
bad at getting up early in the morning
yes
yes the Broadway show and that's bad and
and you're bad for that
what Broadway
do one
oh
what Broadway show would I do I don't
know what do you think people what you
got hairspray brilliant
dragons
I already know them damn songs
thank you thank you you have to be in
Dreamgirls this is hypothetical
what role do you pick are you L'Oreal or
Dina or Effie
let's see yeah go on and think about
this is important
can I just
be like
The Jamie Foxx and you know
can I just own the record company
yes
yes you can well I think um ain't nobody
out singing uh
that that ain't nobody else singing J
Hood or the original yeah and so uh I'll
probably go ahead and rock and rock with
the Beyonce character no no no no no no
that's a little pressure oh yeah nah I
think I'm gonna beat it done I'm gonna
hang back and go on a rally I would pick
Jimmy early now see that's you didn't
offer me that choice I'm sorry you
didn't offer me that trust cause you
know Jimmy
he had the best role in that whole thing
it would be a great gym on I would do it
I get in the Pro I get in the mustache
it'll be funny but then again the
brother had a good song in Dream Girls
oh we are a family I love that song
okay okay so so it's a one-man show you
play everybody yeah I'm gonna have to
problem solved Queen Latifah I love you
crazy rapid fire questions I ever got to
know the answers to these are the truth
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]